alors valérie perrin est à la caisse cet
après midi là mais sa principale
activité ça n'est pas ça c'est elle qui
s'occupe des comptes du cinéma de trop
vite et ce qui fait vivre principalement
le lieu ce sont les entrées ce serait la
salle 3 quand tous les enfants seront
sorties vous pourrez rentrer sur merci
concrètement sur un ticket à plein tarif
à 8 euros
il ya 3 euros 27 kir nous revient à nous
en tant qu'exploitant 3,037 qui va aux
distributeurs ayant droits il ya un euro
39 de taxes autrement dit si le cinéma
ne fait pas d'entrée ils ne gagnent pas
d'argent à l'exception d'une subvention
annuelle de moins de cent mille euros
que l'état reverse pour l'éducation à
l'image le cinéma les carmes est presque
une pme comme une autre à lui de se
débrouiller pour ne pas être dans le
rouge
nous on tourne à un peu plus de cent
cinquante mille entrées et on vit il ya
toujours un mais qu'il fera j'ai
toujours aimé y croire vu sur trois
salles parce qu'on a une forte
concurrence à côté et que l'accès aux
films devient de plus en plus difficile
et donc du coup à partir du moment où on
se partage les films qui sont porteurs
du coup on fait moins d'entrées donc
moins de recettes et aujourd'hui tout va
bien les carmes qui fêtent leurs 20 ans
d'existence sont en équilibre avec même
40000 euros de profits réalisés l'an
dernier et pour que le cinéma aille bien
il y un secteur devenu complètement
incontournable la communication embauché
en cdi depuis peu coralie vallée réalise
le programme de la semaine mais aussi
les très nombreux flyers de maître mot
créativité et réactivité fait il faut
arriver à jongler entre l'identité du
film donc pas complètement dénaturé ça
et la mise en s'offrant la mise en avant
de l'information points donc on va pas
être sûr de la création hyper artistique
à ce moment là c'est parce qu'on cherche
vraiment donner de l'info on pourra
s'éclater quand on va faire des
festivals ou des rétrospectives à avoir
quelque chose de qui ressemble plus à
notre patte aux carmes
enfin voilà une création plus personnel
et pour capter de nouveaux publics les
nouveaux supports ont évidemment fait
leur rentrée
facebook instagram impossible pour le
cinéma d'exister sans les réseaux
sociaux donc là voilà celle instagram
des carmes vous avez enfin on peut avoir
des publications hyper instantanée comme
celle ci est donc là c'était avant-hier
soir hier soir on avait une grosse
rencontre
donc on va dans la salle on prend deux
photos et puis on tag ensuite les
associations qui font partie de la
rencontre le titre du film
voilà le sort de remédier
et pour faire parler du cinéma coralie
n'hésite pas à mettre en ligne quelques
images de films cultes
on a besoin d'être vivant comme ça c'est
aussi hyper dynamique et puis si ça peut
réveiller l'envié de venir en salle de
cinéma autant le faire autant utiliser
passer des canaux qui sont offertes à
tous donc ce serait dommage de pas de
pas s'en servir